time now for pft on yahoo sports peter
king mike florio here with you big
stories in the nfl and one of the things
that will continue to get more and more
attention peter the nfc east is really
really bad two and four cowboys one four
and one eagles one in five giants one in
five washington is this one of the worst
divisions you've ever seen
it might be the worst division i've ever
seen mike because think about the first
place team in this division the dallas
cowboys their offensive line has been
absolutely unequivocally decimated that
was the best part of this team
the quarterback is gone they have no
defensive playmakers in the back end of
their defense
and this the leading team in the
division
and they've won two games
both of them
on walk-off field goals in which the
defense allowed 37 or 34 and 39 points
i don't see how dallas rebounds to win
this
i think philadelphia you would say well
you know the eagles won i mean i
did carson wentz complete anything but
hail mary's the other day i mean i i i
don't i don't like much of
what the eagles are and now with miles
sanders hurt
i think they've got to go to jalen hurts
somehow mike to try to give them some
look on offense
that would surprise a little bit maybe
defensive coordinators with their
massive injuries the giants
come on their offensive line is awful
there's hope for their defense though
and then washington i have no idea what
they're doing at quarterback
uh and their offense is absolutely
feeble mike i
look i've covered the nfl for 37 seasons
and i tried to think of it this morning
and i just do not remember
a division top to bottom that is this
bad
now i think that washington if they
would make the commitment to alex smith
would maybe have a chance to pull
themselves back into it if he can play
like he did or close to like he did a
couple of years ago before that
disastrous injury the eagles are
accustomed to closing late and i like
the idea of getting jalen hurts on the
field not necessarily to replace carson
wentz but you just put your 11 best guys
out there and with that many guys
injured hertz is clearly one of the 11
best at this point you find a roll form
and we saw some of that on sunday and i
i i so i think it's going to be the
eagles or it's going to be washington
but i agree with you the cowboys just
feel like they're in a complete nosedive
at this point it's not going to get any
better i think mike nolan's going to get
fired at some point this team really has
to do some soul searching and even then
i don't know that it's physically
capable of making a difference the
defense is historically bad the offense
without dak prescott is not going to be
nearly as good the offensive line we
took for granted it's gone now for the
most part this team has just fallen
apart and i think the door is open for
philly and washington if they get to
alex smith do you think they'll get to
alex smith at some point not just as an
injury replacement but as the weekend
and week out guy
i think you've got one or two more bad
weeks of kyle allen and then you go to
alex smith i'd like to see smith get a
legitimate chance i agree with you mike
but here's what we're going to see
okay on wild card weekend
we are going to see yet another
illustration of why the nfl seating
system in the playoffs is stupid
absolutely unequivocally stupid
because the lowest seed of the division
winners
always gets a home game it should not be
automatic
should there be any reward this year any
reward
other than peels of laughter
for whatever team that survives the nfc
east that team should be on the road and
should lose
38 to 3
on january 9th in the first playoff game
taking houston mercifully out of the
hole for that first playoff game should
lose 38-3 and then go quietly into the
sunset
yeah and you know peter this is a
discussion for a different day i don't
like the current structure of the nfl
divisions four teams aren't enough to
guard against this kind of a problem
because it seems like every year there's
a quartet of teams that stink and one of
those teams isn't just guaranteed a
playoff spot they're guaranteed a home
game they need to find a way to change
that but uh they seem to be okay with it
so i don't anticipate it changing
anytime soon he's peter king i'm mike
florio we'll see you next time for more
pft on yahoo sports
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports